[Music]
that's by the way that's when you that's
how you know when you've had a bad set
when you when you come upstage and the
club own's like hey man these people
they're idiots don't worry about it man
and you're like well what happened
that's something uh a friend of mine Dan
kman he told me he was the first guy
this I went on the road with he was like
never uh show how you feel it went maybe
the club owner thought it was great but
you come off and you're like I'm so
sorry they're like don't book that guy
again bomb he doesn't want to beat here
he feels terrible he's really bringing
everyone down he's apologizing for
pursuing this career so we should help
him can I tell you with your point thing
you reminded me of a Post-It that's
currently up in my apartment oh I Would
by the way I would love your poits are
there there are going to be like SUV
style photographs of all your poit
submitted into evidence someday like you
see that he was planting the kidnapping
they look like bits but it's actually
sorry go ahead what's on the post you're
saying I'm like Kevin Spacey's journal
in seven yeah exactly yeah by the way
why do serial killers in movies they
have the best sense of design and
calligraphy and penmanship they always
have the weird hanging notebook or
scrapbook that I hope no one opens his
clippings of all the murders I've done
sure would make it easy to pin me point
right to me that I have a bit I did that
in one of my S specials I said uh
killing people I can understand but
journaling who has the time yeah did
Manson do morning
pages that is a deep cut to the artist
way so there's someone doing an exercise
in the workbook going and then back to
learning how to photograph lighthouses I
oh if if I okay this is not that I would
I would never kill anyone but if I was a
serial killer I would if they caught me
I would I would make it very clear that
I well it was the artist way like I
would just keep saying the artist way
like helped me to get you know become
the killer that I was just ruin that
book we've talked about that the idea of
do you just do you just do you well me
me was uh killing a lot of
drifters but it really worked it really
worked the insomnia went away and
[Music]
uh